well it is six months uh since the war
began in ukraine it's also independence
day in ukraine uh we were speaking to
jens stoltenberg the nato uh chief and
and this is what he's been saying to us
we are formally doing two things we are
providing support to ukraine to help
them uphold the right for self-defense
against a brutal aggression of russia
and the other thing nato is doing is to
prevent this war from escalating beyond
ukraine
nato nato allah is not part of the
conflict and we have
increased the military presence
especially in the eastern part of the
alliance to send a very clear message to
moscow that if any nato ally
is attacked the whole alliance will
respond and uk is playing an important
part in those efforts
does that mean we are pushing ourselves
on a war footing
it means that we are supporting ukraine
in their uh defensive war against uh the
russian aggression uh and then it means
that we are
doing what we can to prevent the war
from escalating to directly involve nato
allied countries
and we do that
in the way we have actually preserved
peace uh for more than 70 years as nato
by
having credible deterrence and defense
uh telling moscow clearly that
all allies will protect and defend uh an
ally which is under attack so so that's
the the way nato pursue peace and it's
even more important now
spending targets for nato members is uh
at least two percent that's that's the
hope that's the ambition during the cold
war britain's spending rose to almost
eight percent of gdp um are we entering
uh potentially from what you're saying
um
a sort of
cold war readiness where we are going to
have to look as member countries at
spending more to keep our people safe
we need to spend more uh on the fence uh
and i have been a politician myself for
many many years and and i
know that of course it's always more
tempting to spend on health care on
education on infrastructure
instead of spending uh on the fence
but when we live in a more dangerous
world when we see the aggressive actions
of
president putin against a sovereign
peaceful nation in europe ukraine and
all the threatening rhetoric against
nato allies then we need to invest more
and that's exactly what uh nato allies
are doing the uk uh all this spends more
than two percent but we need to do more
together and
we need to invest in new and more modern
capabilities to ensure that we are able
to also protect all allies in the future
liz trust who may well be our next prime
minister i'm sure you're aware of that
is suggesting three percent of gdp here
in the uk by 2030
do you think that would be enough or
given what we're looking at
and the situation in europe at the
moment we could find ourselves in having
to invest even more as a percentage than
that
the nato guideline is two percent of gdp
and my focus now is to ensure that all
allies meet that guideline the good news
is that more and more allies actually
spend two percent or more on defense
and those who are not yet at two percent
have most of them clear plans in place
to reach a two percent
then two percent is a minimum so of
course we welcome uh
uk and all the others
uh which are aiming at a higher
level of spending than 2 percent
because the brutal reality is that
faced with
russia's
military build up the the will to use
force against the neighbors
there is a need to invest more in
defense what about deliberate damage to
a civil nuclear reactor in ukraine which
potentially could send a plume of
radiation westwards to nato countries
what would nato do that
that's a very dangerous situation and it
can of course also affect uh people in
nato allied countries but it's a
different thing that an armed than an
armed attack
attack on a nato allied country uh the
situation in around or around the
zapuriza uh nuclear power plant the
biggest nuclear power plant in europe is
dangerous and it's reckless of russia to
deploy forces to use the area around the
nuclear power plant as a launching pad
for artillery for attacks on ukrainian
forces so therefore
we need the international atomic energy
agency to have access to be able to
inspect the the site we need the
russians
to
move their forces uh away from the
nuclear power plant and we need um the
the the ukrainian operators to be able
to do their work in a peaceful and uh
controlled environment because
uh what russia does around the saporiza
nuclear power plant is dangerous and
it's dangerous for not only ukraine but
also for the whole of europe between
brexit
and and talks of other european
countries hungary sweden italy leaving
the eu and the nato withdrawal of
afghanistan this time last year which do
you think emboldened putin the most to
exploit exploit i should say europe's
perceived weakness and uh and disunity
and invade ukraine
putin invaded ukraine in 2014
then he illegally annexed a big part of
ukraine uh crimea and he uh started
to move forces and to
support the separatists in the eastern
part of donbass so
russian aggression against ukraine
didn't start in february this year it
started eight years ago uh then of
course what you saw this year was a
full-fledged invasion and that was
invasion invasion they have planned for
many
months
nato allies uh actually predicted the
invasion uh so i think it's uh it's it's
it's no way to try to speculate whether
this is linked to afghanistan or any
other thing the the reality is that uh
putin has an ambition and this is an
ambition has had for a long time to
re-establish
some kind of a
sphero influence where he can control
neighbors
and in particular ukraine and other
countries in his close neighborhood but
do you acknowledge that he is taking the
opportunity to exploit european disunity
what we see and therefore we need to
understand that ukraine is a highly
valued partner of nato we provide
support to ukraine but ukraine is not a
nato ally
so the same security guarantees that
applies for all nato allies united
kingdom for all other allies
they don't apply for ukraine what we
have done for ukraine is that we have
supported them and again united kingdom
has been part of that especially since
2014 with more equipment more training
and that's reason why the ukraine armed
forces are much stronger much more
capable now than in 2014 and why they
have been able to fight back to stand up
against russia's brutal invasion and
actually re-take some territory and and
and
also fight back so the russian offensive
for instance in donbass has stalled so
that's our main purpose my main task is
to
continue to provide support ukraine but
if i may sir i mean you talk about it
not being a nato member ukraine neither
was afghanistan neither was bosnia
neither was kosovo and yet we sent
troops there um does nato regret not
answering the call quicker from ukraine
when they said the writing is on the
wall we need your help on the ground now
well actually we stepped up in 2014 and
uh and we have done a lot since then
nato and nato allies
and actually it was nato and nato allies
that warned clearly against the invasion
uh many months ago and we predicted uh
very exactly
the invasion and the playbook for the
war the the the aim of russia to try to
take kiev and we have no indication that
russia has changed its ambition when it
comes to
controlling uh ukraine
but it is exactly the support from
united kingdom from all the nato allies
that has enabled the at least helped
enable
the ukrainian forces to stand up against
the invasion
and president putin made a big strategic
mistake
when he invaded ukraine he thought it
could
take control of ukraine within days
now russia has
waged war against ukraine for six more
months
and what we see is a war of attrition
where russia is uh
taking a lot of casualties because of
the courage and the capabilities of the
ukrainian armed forces and ukrainian
political leadership you've mentioned
2014 and the invasion the annexation
of crimea a couple of times there
should nato support ukraine's endeavor
to recapture it
we should support ukraine in the right
to
defend themselves a right which is
enshrined in the u.n uh charter ukraine
nato is not part of the conflict but we
support ukraine then it's for ukraine to
decide uh uh
this war will almost likely end at the
negotiating table presidency has stated
that clearly but we know that what
ukraine can achieve on the negotiating
table is totally depend on the strength
on the battlefield and therefore the
best way we can ensure that
the negotiations lead to a result which
is acceptable for ukraine is to provide
military economic financial humanitarian
support ukraine now
so are you suggesting that potentially
president zielinski
should be in a position where he has to
compromise on sovereign territory that
has already been annexed by russia
it's for ukraine to decide our
responsibilities to support them as much
as we can with more uh uh
support with foster
support and i engaged directly with
political leaders throughout the
alliance
to speed up delivery of military uh
support uh and then uh
president zolenska the ukrainian people
how to make the fine decisions on
negotiations and what kind of agreement
they are ready to go into
but the
aim of nato's support to the purpose of
nato's support is to ensure that ukraine
can prevail as an independent sovereign
state in europe we have to understand
that
the easiest way to end this war is for
president putin to stop fighting to stop
attacking
uh if president putin stops fighting we
will have peace if sedenska ukraine
stops fighting
today
then ukraine will cease to exist as
independence over the nation so
therefore we need more military support
to ukraine that's my message okay but
just to clarify are you saying that if
president zelinski says this war is not
over until crimea and
the dumbass region of um ukraine is
taken back into ukrainian sovereign
control if he says not until that has
happened is this war over that is
something that nato would support
we will support ukraine
for as long as it takes we will support
ukraine to prevail as independent
sovereign
state in europe and then
this war will most likely end at the
negotiating table and the outcome of
that
will
totally depend on the strength on the
battlefield and that's the reason why we
support them